We've got a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p here
is a Trumpist commending my integrity.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, my name is Robert [inaudible].
I'm a Trump supporting republican.
I just want to call.
I called you about a week ago and I discussed
what your thoughts on the Antifa member who
attacked the ice facility was and I saw that
you covered it in your show today.
I just wanted to let you know, even though
I probably disagree with you on 90% of policy
issues, I think you're a man of integrity
and I really appreciate the fact that you
covered this.
Even if you put your own spin on it, that
shows to me your denouncing of violence and
your willingness to cover it.
It's a really amazing thing and I think you
represent that you could disagree with someone,
but you still could have integrity and still
learn a lot of things from each other.
So I'd love to talk to you in person sometime
or on your show, but I keep up the good work
and even though I disagree with you, I'll
still be listening.
So thanks a lot.
Thank you so much.
Uh, the, by the way, that was also Gavin mechanism.
I'm kidding.
Um, yeah, I, I'm not a, I'm not afraid of
covering these stories like, uh, the, the
one that's referenced there, uh, because I
know that we have the principles on our side
and we have the facts on our side and I am
not going to a cult or hide, um, anything
from you on the basis of trying to create
a particular picture.
As I've said historically, I've self-censored
because I just don't want to, uh, hit certain
Hornet's nests with a stick sometimes for
my own personal sanity.
Uh, but I appreciate the comment and, uh,
I will keep calling it the way I see it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about a judge dismissing the
lawsuit from one of those teenagers from the
Maga hat, Washington DC fiasco of a few months
back.
Uh, we will talk about whether 10,000 steps
a day really is a requirement for health,
uh, and much, much more.
I have one of those fitness trackers and I'll
tell you what my step goal is every day.
It is a closely guarded secret.
Great.
But I will reveal it on today's bonus show.
Get access to the bonus show by becoming either
a member or a patron.
I'll speak to you that the David Pakman show@davidpacman.com.
[inaudible].